[Music]
i give salam to my people in bangladesh
salaam to the people of marrakesh okay
assalamu alaikum what happened today
brothers and sisters and defense hope
you guys are well inshallah uh so we had
a sister i've got your name still wasn't
it
jasmine yeah okay sister jasmine came to
the park if i'm not mistaken
last year and we had a discussion about
a doubt that you had
so she she wanted to share a story
that at one moment i think he was
doubting islam
yeah so we just want to know for example
because as the people as a brother in
the dawah
we really want to know for example as
youngsters what you're going through
what's causing you to have doubts what's
led to it yeah
so inshallah and um sister jasmine tell
us a bit about
your journey to islam when did you start
kind of practicing or start practicing
uh you just tell them a bit about it
growing up i didn't have the i didn't
have as much knowledge i was more
grown up on culture basically yeah more
basically growing up on culture more so
i started looking at um
youtube videos yours to be honest i
started looking at yours and now i
started getting it
getting into it and then i decided to
take shahada again
because i realized i wasn't taking it
seriously it was around like
it was kind of it was kind of after me
and you had that
so it was after me and you had that talk
so after me you had that tool
yeah so that happened and then
i started actually doing a research
rather than be ignorant because what i
used to do here i used to look at the
christians
to think oh you know what they have a
little bit of a point and stuff like
that but then i realized it makes no
logical sense
so i came to that conclusion so i had a
lot of doubts i used to see
like obviously no names but like people
backed by in here and there in the park
and it made me think
okay so if black guy is not allowed why
are you able to do it yourself
and maybe it made me think so if this is
what islam is about because the thing is
the christians the reason why they don't
confront each other is because
they they all just don't care about the
the book is already like gone it's
already
written by so many people they don't
care but we've asked we took it
seriously so
when i saw the conflict it made me want
to leave it done because it made me
think if this is what it's about
are you talking about muslims sometimes
fighting each other are you talking
about
individuals who come to this park like
myself and
you know what you know what both both
because when i see both muslims
confronting each other
whether even if they're sure it's one
thing to debate there's another thing to
fight like you knew there was this one
video i know it's been happened years
ago
what's his name um i don't want to say
names the shia got chased by so many
sunni boys
when i saw that it made me want to leave
islam because how could you get chased
because you're a different sect
i know okay look i know some things
might not be the best
like views or whatnot but it's not so
it's not good to do that is what i'm
trying to say
and when i saw that i just made you
think don't be a part of it
so other stuff like for example you
mentioned something you mentioned
something um
specific yeah you said there were
certain things that led to that so
you've seen muslims fighting each other
etc uh and you you mention a specific
person which i'm not going to name
um that you said his back backbiting
was something that yeah yeah and we'll
talk about this and remember i'll give
you the example about
brother issa may i love mercenary who
died yeah he passed away
and this is the very same brother that i
i was so so enraged and angry about
because
brother issa he was somebody who came to
the park
and he was someone who was a i would say
the finest example you know
yeah yeah his smile his character his
behavior his athlete
his adapt in this park was unmatched and
this park is not the same without him
i'll be very honest with you it's not
the same without him and subhanallah
this brother that you was talking about
as well to back bite him
somebody who has passed away that really
annoyed me that really hurt me yeah
so sometimes like i don't want that
conflict to happen i'll be honest with
you these conflicts
i don't want to happen that's why i
never ever i avoided
that brother had problems with us for a
long time yeah and i tried to avoid it
you know why
because i don't want youngsters to be
watching that and be like look at these
guys fighting each other
because the akin institute in america
done a study then i researched
and they found out that one of the main
reasons why a lot of muslims leave islam
is because into conflict in a conflict
and that is a fine example when you came
to me today
and said brother ali you know what so
those are things i saw in the park
and you mentioned this brother which i
said don't mention his name that's
that's sad because let alone you as a
muslim
brother isis family they got in contact
with me
and they were so angry like you didn't
have nothing good to say about
brother issa someone like isa if it was
me i'll say you know what sometimes i'm
controversial
sometimes i do things that upset people
but to come and pick on brother issa
sorry
people someone like brother esau and
somebody who's just passed away
for you to come and make him look like
he's someone bad
oh alamostan don't watch his video etc
how did you feel
did you see that video by the way how
did you feel when you saw some
a believer a muslim justifying
a believer from the videos i saw i never
saw a single thing he said that wrong
i'm not
my honest he didn't do it yeah i didn't
see him
like if he if he was like a fight or
something in a park i'd understand but
he didn't do anything
obviously he had a sweet personality
that's what i asked for personally i
feel like you have every right to feel
the way you felt because i wouldn't want
to see it
i'm thinking what did the guy do and we
found out later which is why
he's so profound dawood had a interview
with him
um before yeah and we found and
subhanallah it's as if he was speaking
from the dead
as if this interview came out later it
was recorded long time ago
but once he passed away the who told me
about him
told me and in that video he left this
group
you have this group who comes here and
everyone's in the park yeah
brother mansoor
all of us in the park we go and eat
together we talk together
we move together and even if we say
we're not going to talk to somebody we
don't talk to that person together
the only person that doesn't come and
join us is this group
in the past you'll even see them moving
around in groups
and we're thinking subhanallah says in
the quran to be merciful to the muslims
towards each other be merciful
why but that's the thing is why now let
me tell you something sister yeah some
people are gonna come and say oh you're
planted
did i tell you to come here did i tell
you to come and approach me
i approached you okay taken off by allah
if this is because i know let me see
some people gonna think
that i probably staged this i swear upon
allah may allah deal with me
if i ask you to come did i ask you to
come tell us what happened
so i approached ali approached ali
because i i mentioned i came here for
the same reason that i just went to
what's going on but
i saw a lot of things so i just went to
ask ali about it
i just told him that i felt really upset
that there was a lot of conflict from
this
i'm not trying to be with this couple of
people so i wanted to adjust it and see
why why because i want to know whether
it's from your sect or is it from music
i don't even know the sex that you guys
are
on about so i'm just trying to see which
one it was exactly and that's why so the
people who are watching this
brothers and sisters while i sometimes
when there's conflict with other muslims
we avoid it
we try our best because you know why we
know our youngsters who were watching
this
like this sister she was on the verge of
leaving islam
yeah she was on the verge of she may
have done that
why because unnecessary conflict
oh you don't take from my teacher yaki
what is wrong with you
who is his teacher it's someone yeah the
point is this
the issue is this that arrogance
arrogance because shaytan's full
everybody talks about this here do you
know shaytan was a worshiper of allah
and then you know he was very righteous
so allah says in the quran when we ask
the angels to prostrate
all of them proceed except they believe
in places not an angel he was at the
ranks of the angels
arrogance arrogance arrogance the way
when we move if i move around like i'm
an arrogant person
self-righteous oh this guy's misguided
he's misguided he's missed our mashallah
made jannah just for you
wow bravo so allah made the whole jannah
for you and your buddies and your homies
and the reason why i'm so angry for the
sake of allah is because we see
you're the one who came with your own
mafia off camera and said
certain muslims caused me to nearly
leave islam or i left islam
and that's a burden upon us when we
fight with each other for
silly petty stuff oh brother you're not
from my clique but bun you when you
click
ban you and you click who gives a dumb
about your clip just because
i was selfie with this what that so many
youth and this is evidence brother and
sister
yakin institute carried out a study that
shows muslim youth
leave islam just like the sister why
because interconflict
unnecessary conflict so we ask people
who are watching there inshallah
and you're a muslim now mayor bless your
sister mubarak
is going well we ask allah to keep you
firm yeah and wallahi with this attitude
of arrogance
and one thing as muslims we do is we
look at someone's outer appearance
all right where's the hijab look at his
beard and phone yeah
okay good that's good don't get me
twisted how many how many people
would look at this sister or she doesn't
wear a hijab oh
star for allah aki yes the hijabs you
know
you yeah and you're working on it but to
come and demonize her
or she's like this okay i'm so sorry
i've seen a lot of hijabis
that do a lot of wrong stuff and i've
seen a lot of sisters who don't wear
hijab at praise allah
the point is this allah
allah says when you slaughter an animal
yeah we're in this
eid yeah when this was an animal it's
not the blood or the flesh that reaches
allah
but it is the taqwa so what's allah
trying to tell you allah is telling you
when you sacrifice an animal it is not
the blood
nor the flesh that reaches allah it is
the taqwa
allah says in the quran that he has
given us garments clothing
to hide our shame allah says the taqwa
the clothing
of taqwa is more beloved allah says in
the quran
facing east or west is not righteousness
brother
don't think oh i face the kaaba so
righteous
allah seen facing the east or the west
is not righteousness
and lastly i'll finish off this allah
says when the munafi kun were
building the masjid yeah masjid when
they were building that masjid
to plot against the muslims allah says
it is more deserving
that you worship in the masjid of taqwa
from the clothes that you wear to the
animal that you sacrifice to the
direction that you face
to the masjid that you're in
but what do we do oh that person he's
got a beard he must be so righteous
he's done a video with 100 books behind
him allahu akbar
subhanallah brothers and sisters let's
look at the inner dynamics of someone
and let's not judge people and avoid
these
petty conflicts that cause our
youngsters our youth our sisters our
brothers
to leave islam is there any last words
you would say sorry i went on a bill i'm
very passionate
is there anything you would like to say
i don't have anything to say
okay may allah bless you sister
inshallah if you have any doubt if
there's anything that you want to ask
will you hear us your brothers
we're here in sha allah to help you
inshallah to make sure we're not here to
judge
well i i never i don't think i'm better
than you well you might be better than
me in allah's eyes 100 times
we ask allah to make you firm inshallah
and yeah may allah bless you for your
time assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters our aim here is to
dialogue
we're here to dialogue with our
youngsters we're not here to judge
people
we want people to come and open up to us
talk to us let's have a heart to heart
inshallah and we invite anybody around
the world you come to speak this corner
come visit us
if you need anything we're here